salut à vous peuple d internet deuxième
vidéo donc jour 2 est deuxième ouverture
de ce calendrier de l'avent youtube est
ce que j'espère que ça vous plaît s'il
vous plaît d'ailleurs vous pouvez
toujours le signifier avec ceux ci
alors c'est pas en faisant ça devant
l'écran mais ça on le sent directement
lights la vidéo ça fait toujours plaisir
durant tous cas leur vie d'avant parfois
je l'aborderai aussi des vrais sujets
des vrais thèmes en plus de l'idée
cadeau du jour
alors là l'idée cadeau elle va prendre
toute la vidéo c'est un jeu super groupe
je vais vous dire d'abord comment je les
trouvais c'est quand j'étais en dédicace
à deux sites à lyon il y avait une pile
de jeu derrière moi et du coup je les
regardais assez souvent
alors oui on peut redire que si j'ai
regardé un jeu assez souvent c'est qu'il
y avait personne à la dédicace n'en
utilise très nombreuses c'était cool
mais il m'avait attiré je lui ai acheté
avant de partir et j'ai surkiffé ce jeu
ça s'appelle agent trouble est ce que je
dois vous rappeler que cette vidéo comme
toutes les autres ne sont pas des
placements produits non je ne pas le
rappeler
alors agent trouble c'est une bête
d'idées les règles sont ultra simple
mais la stratégie allez juste parfaite
je ne sais pas quel nom du créateur
alexander me chan est belle tu sais quoi
pour toi je fais une ola tout seul
j'ai des composés parce que j'étais
aujourd'hui la prépa du jeu la première
fois les autres fois ça va mais la
première fois à les ultras relou parce
qu'il ya plus de vingt-quatre sachets à
faire soi même un petit peu de dire i
way dans ce jeu il faut être au minimum
quatre joueurs et ça peut aller jusqu'à
huit joueurs tous les joueurs du jeu
vous recevoir une carte avec un lieu le
lieu et les communs pour tout le monde
là par exemple c'est le garage ok donc
on imagine tous les joueurs vont
recevoir la carte garage et en plus du
lieu chaque joueur reçoit un rôle une
espèce de personnages mais c'est très
simple à l'ats par exemple nous avons un
gérant un électrotechnicien technicien
en pneumatiques un laveur de voiture un
conducteur un motard il ya
réceptionniste n'ont pas d'hôtels des
dégâts a donc ça n'aurait aucun sens
une carte en plus dont je vous parlerai
après dance est plus logique d'en parler
maintenant c'est fait en plus une carte
question il ya un des joueurs on sait
pas qui évidemment il va recevoir la
carte espion ça veut dire qu'il ne sait
pas dans quel lieu sont les autres n'y a
aucun indice est toujours le même carte
espion le but de tous ceux qui ont un
lieu ça va être de démasquer qui est
l'espion ça c'est leur le job c'est leur
rôle est le but du mondial la carte
question c'est de savoir dans quels
lieux se trouvent tous les autres à
partir du moment où il trouve le lieu
il a gagné la partie c'est très
important à savoir pour la suite
et à partir du moment où les autres
agents décident d'accuser un espion de
l'être s'ils ont tort perdre la partie
donc l'espion gamme automatiquement la
partie ces dernières qui n'a pas trop le
droit à l'erreur dans un premier temps
il faut savoir que tout le monde a aussi
en plus une carte avec les trente lieux
possibles il ya trente que possible
l'ambassade l'avion la banque à base
militaire le poste de police et la
station spatiale le cirque les croisades
l'université les jours etc
c'est vraiment très très fourni et la
partie elle se déroule de la manière
suivante le premier joueur va poser une
question un autre joueur et ce joueur là
va devoir répondre à cette question en
restant dans son personnage si l'air est
cette chemise dans le garage
il faut qu'il réponde
ces pionniers dans un garage voyez
l'idée une fois qu'il a répondu il va
poser une question à une autre personne
et cette personne qu'on leur a répondu
posera une question à une autre personne
etc etc
il n'y a pas de sens y'a pas de tour il
n'y a pas de logique dans le sens où on
peut très bien se faire un ping pong à 2
alors qu on est huit à jouer pendant un
certain temps et dans les questions
qu'on va poser notre but n'oubliez pas
en tant que agents et de trouver
l'espion donc on va poser une question
pour voir si l'autre c'est bien dans
quel lieu où on se trouve
mais forcément comme l'espion est parmi
nous et qu'il nous en temps il faut pas
trop lui donner des indices sur le lieu
au mont et vous voyez toute la
difficulté du truc alors je sais que ça
peut paraître un petit peu confus c'est
souvent le cas quand on explique un jeu
ça à part être plus clair avec un
exemple juste rappel des faits tout le
monde a reçu une carte avec un lieu
commun là c'est le garage en
l'occurrence le job de l'espion c'est de
trouver que tout le monde est dans un
garage et le job des autres personnes de
chercher qui est l'espion et donc qui ne
sait pas où est ce qu'on met donc
imaginons que j'ai reçu cette carte là
garage et que moi je sois un motard est
que la personne en face c'est aussi une
carte garage avec marc et gérant je vais
lui poser une question pour savoir si
l'espion pas mais dans ma question je
vais pas trop donner d'avis sur le lieu
puisque j'ai pas envie que l'espion en
lui-même sache où on est donc je vais
dire par exemple vous êtes ici pourquoi
vous voilà dans ma tête je suis un
motard et ma moto vous êtes ici pourquoi
élu en tant que gérant forcément il veut
répondre sans donner trop d'indicés
parce qu'il sait pas si je suis moi
aussi je suis l'espion c'est possible
c'est 3 aller standard donc à venir ben
moi je travaille ici et là pour
l'instant le jeu n'avance pas c'est à
dire que je sais toujours pas s'il est
l'espion le 'patron' indices lui non
plus et on se se suspicieux yonne un
petit peu dirais-je donc comme c'est lui
qui allie la question maintenant il peut
poser une question à qui veut sauf à moi
pour que le jeu avance un petit peu tout
à l'heure je me se tromper en disant
qu'on avait
de revenir sur une personne scénarii que
j'avais inventé pour jouer à trois
joueurs mais ça se joue plutôt à partir
de quatre joueurs donc bien là cette
personne-là va poser une question à
quelqu'un d'autre par exemple à à
l'espion imaginons que la personne qu
une question à lescure ou encore une
fois personne ne sait qui est qui
donc le gérant va dire par exemple ce
que quelqu'un s'occupe de vous et moi en
tant qu'espions là je ne sais pas du
tout de quoi il parle ou est-ce qu'on
est donc il va falloir que je l'en
brouille en faisant semblant de savoir
un peu je suis donc je vais lui dire non
personne pour le moment que j'espère que
ça va aller vite
c'est ce que je me dis qu ils
s'inquiètent de quelque chose je réponde
à ce quelque chose donc je donne pas
encore vingt dix et là c'est un cas
assez difficile quand je joue au jeu
télé ce pion et maintenant tu dois poser
une question à quelqu'un était censé
connaître le lieu faire semblant de
savoir où tu es pour pas de faire
griller donc là tu se réfère à tout ce
qu'a eue avant pour essayer d'inventer
ta question par exemple je vais poser en
question à quelqu'un je veux lui dire
j'en ai marre d'être ici ça fait combien
de temps que vous attendez vous c'est
tout je sais pas où on est mais comme on
m'a demandé s'il y avait quelqu'un qui
s'occupait de moi je sais que cette
question à une certaine logique dans la
réponse excepté à etc sans oublier que
vous avez toujours la carte avec les
trente lieux possibles
donc quand l espion forcément il faut un
peu faire gaffe quand tu la regardes
parce qu'il n'y a qu'une personne qui
elle réellement besoin de regarder ce
cas c'est la personne qui sait pas où on
est et des fois ça va très très vite et
des fois c'est fait selon je vous donner
un exemple concret dans une partie qu'on
a fait
j'ai réussi à trouver l'espion en
quelques tours parce que j'ai posé la
question quand est-ce qu'on est payé
tout est scandée pays comme on était
tous censés travailler au même endroit
jeudi côté ce qu'on ait payé la
personnelle ma vie la fin de mois où je
crois au plus tard le 5 ans toute
manière c'est la loi c'était la loi sauf
qu'on était en croisade
donc je vais forcément je savais que sa
réponse elle était complètement à quoi
d j'ai trouvé que c'était elle l'espion
en l'audience c'est hyper simple à jouer
ça se joue jusqu'à 10 joueurs c'est
hyper rythmée et dans ce genre de jeu ce
que j'aime bien c'est qu'en jouant à 8
joueurs on est toujours impliqué dans le
jeu on n'est jamais réellement en train
d'attendre son tour passe on est
toujours en train d'écouter d'analyser
les autres et où c'est vraiment très
très cool je ne sais pas du tout quand
est ce que ce jeu a été créé et je vous
dis j'ai découvert ça moi ya deux mois
et joue mais le lien évidemment dans la
description pour trouver le jeu dans la
description vous trouverez également et
ça c'est pas une intéressante
les places pour le spectacle à l'olympia
le 22 septembre quelle bonne idée de
cadeau de noël
et quelle bonne idée de cadeau pour moi
aussi de savoir que vous viendrez
j'espère que vous serez là vous pouvez
mettre tous en l'air si vous avez aimé
la vidéo vous pouvez vous abonner si ce
n'est pas encore fait et comme c'est un
calendrier dit noël rendez vous demain
pour la case numéro trois à six heures
du matin
ouais ouais ciao
[Musique]